covet 19 has taken a heavy toll
on our people societies and economies
the var is still a dangerous threat
we must strengthen our public health
systems
more than one billion jobs have been
administered so far globally
raising hopes that we can soon return
to a more normal life italy holds the
g20
presidency this year and we believe
addressing the pandemic remains our
foremost priority only an effective
synergy between science and governments
can ensure
that the worst of this pandemic is
behind
us and that we are better prepared for
the future
health is a global public good it must
be accessible to all people
in all countries and this is why
the italian g20 presidency and the
european commission decided
to host a global health summit on may
21st
in rome together we want to agree
on a roam declaration of principles
such principles can be a powerful guide
to prevent future crises
and to be more resilient in the face of
future global health threats
billions of people around the world
urgently
wait for answers not only to fight this
pandemic
but also to be better prepared for the
next one
you